the gyro can experience how did you feel
about when people would play the game
competitively and they would turn all
the textures off so I yeah that's that
especially is a sore point with the
artists that have labored for years to
build these glorious textures and then
you get the people that just turn them
down and there's two reasons to turn
them down you turn them down to help
performance in some cases in the early
days and especially the early graphics
cards you would get higher framerate if
you turned him down so you'd have less
latency in your response times but
there's also the even more de farías
thing about turning them all down to
improve the contrast on your enemy
acquisition yeah I
so people want this almost flat shaded
world so that any moving set of pixels
there just turn and fire at that and
that's I'm I never came to really great
terms with that where I always thought
on and the early days of eSports and
gaming we did always insist that people
have to play with at least plausible
resolutions there because we want our
game to look good we want people that
are looking at it for the first time
seeing these professionals play it I am
you know we don't want them to look at
that and say well this game looks like
garbage it's all flat shaded or blurry I
am and luckily computers got fast enough
that people could start playing at the
frame rates that they wanted even with
the full textures running in it I am but
the whole pace of doing that I am kind
of the eSports and the competitive
gaming was very interesting we saw the
dawn of that with doom but it's been
pretty surprised it's been amazing the
state that it's taking it's gotten to
today where I remember when we did the
quake red anihilation tournament I gave
away my first Ferrari as grand prize and
I was thinking really this is just the
most over-the-top thing this is going to
be unmatched for years and it was only a
year later that there was some other
tournament with $100,000 prize coming
out so that went on went much quicker
than I expected and then today you have
just them the amazing celebrity of the
top pro players it's it's again it's
great to see the path that it's taken it
really is and it's very interesting to
see that they're now like legitimate
sports stars and they make a ton of
money whereas if you were a kid 10 15
years ago your parents would tell you're
wasting your time this is nonsense why
are you playing these games
but now you have a legitimate
opportunity to be a professional game
player although I do I get I ain't
there's a hazard there where what's this
Jamie what are you pulling up top
earners this year compared to the top
Tiger Woods how much you want in the
Masters in the top Indy 500 earner Tiger
Woods 1/2 million in the Masters the top
quake players 1 3 million 121 8 under 72
well it's not quick what game is that
dota
what is that what's dota it's a
different game than quake but it's very
popular right now
what's a stand for I've never even heard
of it it's a valve game I am you know
it's a it's a MOBA massively online
battle arena game directing all the
different little characters down there
and that along with especially League of
Legends even beyond that I not as
popular in the United States but is just
amazing overseas where they like if you
look at the numbers for things people
think oh the Superbowl like the height
of all competitive sports whatever and
they a lot of these eSports games
especially in South Korea are they dwarf
those numbers and really and some people
are just variable yeah not aware of this
where you just get millions of people
tuning in an enormous arenas to write
they play in these gigantic places with
you look at this oh my God look at this
arena that looks like 30,000 people that
looks like a UFC event yeah yeah
actually a lot bigger than you let's the
event is that one should know about that
one in particular they have some really
enormous Vegas UFC event we ever had was
55,000 people yeah they've been well
over that that's crazy
that's amazing